[Music]
why do we buy certain products or choose
certain brands this is the sort of
question advertisers have always asked
and there are no easy answers however
there is a handy tool that helps
companies explore this and similar
questions and it's called the focus
group until the 1940s market research
was often quantitative using things like
sales figures and customer polls to
track consumption but this changed
during World War two
sociologists Robert Merton and Paul
Lazar Feld set out to learn how
unprecedented exposure to wartime
propaganda was affecting the public
instead of polling large numbers of
people with straightforward questions
and quantifiable answers the researchers
conducted in person interviews sometimes
with small groups engaging them in more
open discussions later this method was
picked up by the advertising industry
with the help of consultants like
austrian-born psychologist Ernest dictor
who first coined the term focus group
this new technique was a type of
qualitative research focused on the
nature of people's preferences and
thoughts it couldn't tell marketers what
percentage of people buy a certain
product or brand but it could tell them
more about the people who do their
reasoning for doing so and even the
unconscious motivations behind those
reasons rather than providing definite
conclusions for business and sales focus
groups would be used for exploratory
research generating new ideas for
products and marketing based on paper
understanding of consumer habits for
example early focus groups found that
contrary to popular opinion at the time
wives often had more influence than
their husbands when choosing which car
to buy so Chrysler shifted gears by
marketing cars directly to women and dr.
dictor himself conducted focus groups
for Mattel to learn what girls wanted in
a doll the result was the original
Barbie doll so how does a focus group
work
first companies recruit between six and
ten participants according to specific
criteria that meet their research
objectives they could be mothers of
children between five and seven for
teenagers planning to buy a new phone in
the next three months this is often done
through professional recruiters who
manage lists of people who've agreed to
participate in focus groups for payment
or other rewards during a session
participants are asked to respond to
various prompts from the group moderator
like sharing their opinions on a certain
product or their emotional reactions to
an advertisement they may even be asked
to do seemingly unrelated tasks like
imagining brands as animals in a zoo the
idea is that this can reveal useful
information about the participants
feelings that traditional questions
might not get to beyond these basics
many variations are possible a focus
group may have two or more moderators
perhaps taking opposite sides on a
question or a researcher might be hidden
in the focus group unknown to other
participants to see how their answers
can be influenced and the whole process
may also be observed by researchers
through a one-way mirror but although
they can provide valuable insight focus
groups do have their limitations and one
of the main ones is that the simple act
of observing something can change it
this principle is called observer
interference the answers participants
give are likely to be affected by the
presence of the researchers social
pressure from the rest of the group or
simply knowing that they're taking part
in a focus group and because researchers
often use a small sample size in a
specific setting it's hard to generalize
their results the findings that
researchers do reach from focus groups
are often tested through experiments and
data gathering those put numbers on
questions like how many potential
customers there are and what price
they'd be willing to pay this part of
the process changes as technology
evolves but focus groups have remained
largely the same for decades perhaps
when it comes to the big important
questions
there's no substitute for people
genuinely interacting with each other
[Music]